la mémoire est un fil tendu entre le
passé le présent et l'avenir
la mémoire et l'histoire coexistent elle
se conjugue elles se vivent ensemble les
acteurs du travail de mémoire
bien entendu sont les ce qu'ils ont vécu
directement quand ils existent encore
mais je crois que en fait les acteurs
bien ça doit être des professeurs ça
doit être les historiens la mémoire qui
nous appartient à tous c'est un bien
commun et nous avons la responsabilité
d'une génération vis à vis de l'autre de
faire vivre cette mémoire ce flambeau
mémorielle ne doit jamais s'éteindre
il est important avec tous ces acteurs
de pouvoir reconstruire un chemin de
mémoire afin que et bien des jeunes
générations en particulier connaissent
mieux leur pays d'à façon de tisser
construit la façon dont notre république
a été secoué mais préserver la façon
dont les combattants se sont engagés
pour sauver le pays
d'obscurantisme et tout cela est
absolument essentiel on a vécu des
moments durs ces dames et un essai
moment ils sont ancrés dans nos mémoires
personnelles mais également dans notre
mémoire collective
c'est ce qui permet à toute une
génération de se lever et de résister
que ce soit face à la crise terroristes
à ces attaques barbares mais également
en face à cette crise sanitaire qui
laissera une trace dans notre mémoire
collective